when I drift off I will dream that you
it's how I see you I want to talk about
hot guys new haircut he has a new
haircut everyone's talking about it
they're like obsessed with it I want to
know what your first reaction was when
you guys first off it's just
disappointed that audience loved one of
those you could rock that do not tell me
what I want there and you're kind of a
jerk if you don't do yeah I can't wait
to grow that when I get to grow my hair
baby but for him like you know he's not
gonna style that and like you gotta use
some product when you have a mohawk he's
not gonna do that and then I was
thinking I'm not sure that how that's
gonna end up like it's not gonna just be
like a weird like soft sort of baby hair
thing that just comes forward like that
it's like kind of yeah when you get a
short hair that it's easier but it's
actually not dude that new haircut help
add to your performance at all yes I was
jealous because I thought it looked so
cool yeah and he can pull it off
was it not lice related I thought there
was some it was an issue there was an
issue I thought yeah we had to yeah
something happened yeah it wasn't their
fashion there's a health related issue
the Avengers take on light hair like I
didn't know that he pitched it to you
guys we're always encouraging the
actress
so when you first saw it you were like
yes this is amazing or did you regret it
we love it we like crazy
[Music]
you